[Applause]
all right and yeah hi everyone and so
I'm a data scientist working at tails
comm and as well as being a data
scientist I'm also a big fan of dogs as
you can see if I some of the pictures
which is convenient for me because tails
calm is a dog food company and what we
offer is tailor-made dog food and so how
this works in practice
and we're a subscription service if you
have a dog you sign up and you tell us a
lot of information about your dog so
about their breed their gender whether
neutered are not health issues what they
used to feed all of these things and
then we have an algorithm which works
out from all of our different dry food
recipes that we have which combination
of those recipes is going to be the
right recipe for your dog that month and
so our algorithms got two main jobs so
first it's got to provide great
nutritious food for our dogs because
that's what our customers expect but as
well as that it's going to provide tasty
food because if the dogs don't like
eating the food and then the customers
not going to reorder and there's no
point in all of the great nutrition work
that we've put in to get your food to
your door and so what this is called
in the dog food circles is palatability
which is basically how do we know that
the food we're sending out each month
taste good to your dog as well as being
great for your dog and so obviously we
can't answer this question directly
because we ask the dogs and they can't
really tell us exactly why they like the
food so we need to use a little bit of
data so one of the approaches we're
using at tails calm is a network
analysis so I'm using the library called
Network X if you've not used this
library before I'd recommend giving it a
go it's pretty good fun and network
analysis is basically a way of
representing your data as a graph with
nodes and edges and it helps you
understand the relationships between
your data points as well as the
significance of the data points
themselves and we're using it here is
like a visualization tool to see if we
visualize our dry dog food recipes that
we're sending out to customers as a
network can we then understand using
that structure you know which recipes
work which ones the dogs like and which
ones the dogs don't like as much so I'm
just going to walk you through a little
bit about how this works to give you an
idea of network analysis and
say some of the stuff within a tails so
first we're gonna start with a bunch of
our kibbles these are our dried dog feed
ingredients and we're just gonna lay
them out in a circular pattern like this
these are the notes of our graph then
we're gonna add some edges so here I'm
drawing the line and if these two tables
have appeared in a bag of dog food
together and as you can see there's
quite a lot of lines connecting all the
cables together which basically means
that most of our food has appeared in
the bag of food with the rest of our
food which makes sense because they're a
tailor-made dog food brand if we were
just sending out the same five recipes
you weren't really be doing that job
very well but it doesn't really help us
understand exactly what's going on in
our food so now we resize it so now I
scaled the width of the lines and the
size of my nodes to represent the sort
of frequency of that combination or that
kibble appearing in the bags together so
now you can start to see some patterns
of where our high use common
combinations are and where are more rare
ones are and now let's compare that for
one of our dots and see what the graph
looks like for customers that don't like
the food and end up canceling compared
to customers with happy dogs that keep
ordering our food ultimately you can see
there's not all that much difference
right now about how they look because
they're you know the insights that were
looking for are quite fine if it was
that easy we wouldn't be having to use a
technique like network analysis to
understand what's good and what isn't so
now we're going to color them and so
here I've scales I've taken the graph
and I've colored it with kind of like a
conditional probability that this
combination of this kibble ended up
resulting in a palatability in a
cancellation for the customer not liking
the food or not where red is the least
flavorful ones the ones that resulted in
the highest cancellations and our blue
ones are really high performing recipes
and so you can see a few insights coming
out of here already so first we've got
this guy in the top right here and top
left for you he's you know it's a pretty
big red dot which means it's relatively
high use and there's all red lines
coming out of it which means everywhere
it goes it tends to result in kind of
more likely to be cancellations so this
is something that we can look at and say
okay this is the next ingredient that we
can try in
proven we can Rene beat us on that and
try and improve the formulation to make
it tastier for the dogs and then you've
got other ones like this guy down here
where it's like in of itself it's it's
it's not too bad you know it tastes okay
it kind of is not too red and you got a
few red lines coming out of it but
you've also got a few blue lines coming
out of it so it's not maybe it's not the
ingredient itself that's inherently not
tasty it's just when it's paired with
other ingredients sometimes that doesn't
work for different dogs and so this is
the type of thing that we can feed back
into the algorithm and kind of down
weight the likelihood that this kibble
will be paired with other ones where we
can see red lines on the graph and uh
plate the likelihoods that you know with
the blue lines that they appear together
and that way we can kind of teach the
algorithm basically to always be
selecting tasty food we're hiring a bait
you're engineer
[Applause]